most people are are so sufficiently  disconnected that they aren't aware of  what brings them Joy or what is driving  their decisions or you know the  activities that would gird their life  with more purpose and fulfillment and  meaning and the like and I think a  process of starting to better understand  yourself and what makes you tick is  Having the courage to share your story  we all have our we all have a story  right and that courage is born out of a  choice to be vulnerable like the  vulnerability is strength because it  takes bravery and courage to share  something when you can summon that and  and engage with that there is a level of  self-efficacy and self-esteem that  derives from that that allows you to be  more self-integrated and self-actualized  to stand in that power to Adorn that  crown and like claim your truth and your  path and I think it is true that